Republicans not Democrats are in fact
looking for answers this morning about
why they fell short of historical
expectations in these midterms so for
more on that let's bring in our chief
election and campaign correspondent
Robert Costa he joins us now Bob good
morning to you Gail and I have been
trading articles here this morning uh
right-leaning newspapers The Wall Street
Journal on the New York Post uh coming
out pretty strongly against the former
president Donald Trump with losses in
2018 losses in 2020 and now losses in
2022 is it time to move on or what are
you hearing that's exactly what's
happening inside the Republican party
right now and on the editorial page of
the Wall Street Journal this morning
it's a reckoning about former president
Trump and about where the Republican
party is going to go from here for weeks
now we've been hearing about how Trump
wants to get into the 2024 race this
month but now so many of my top
Republican sources on Capitol Hill in
the 2024 ranks they're saying maybe it's
time to go toward Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis or give an outsider like
Maryland governor Larry Hogan who I
spoke to yesterday a chance to carve a
new path for the GOP so a lot of
turbulence right now a lot of
conversations about the future
I know Bob the the headlines are pretty
stunning in the Wall Street Journal
Trump is The gop's Biggest Loser the New
York Post trumpety dumpity and they're
being very uh flattering about Ron
DeSantis so is he clearly now Trump's
biggest opponent and what about Mike
Pence how does he fit into all of this
with a new book coming out the big
question Gail for governor DeSantis is
whether he wants to get into a messy
complicated political fight against the
former president we've already seen that
Trump on the campaign Trail this year
has called the Florida governor Ron de
sanctimonious that was a political
warning shot to DeSantis I'm told that
if you get in it's going to only get
worse so DeSantis he's in his early 40s
he has to wonder his friends tell me
whether he wants that kind of fight at
this stage in his career in Pence he's
coming out with a book next week called
so help me God quite a title there and
he's going to detail for the first time
his private conversations with former
president Trump especially in and around
the capital attack
all right we are all still watching
thank you very much Bob